hello and welcome to the point so last
week Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 came out
and it's fair to say the reception
hasn't been great though it seemed to
have a few good ideas thrown in there
thps 5 had all the hallmarks of a game
rush through the door
Bhaiji why poor flow uninspired design
loads of repetition and straight up
broken features one explanation for this
might be that activations contract that
the Birdman is reportedly set to run out
at the end of this year meaning past
2015 they may not have the rights to
produce another Hawk game so some have
speculated the thps 5 was rushed at the
door early to ensure Activision got one
more payday added franchise now whether
or not this is true deadlines and the
effect that it has on a games overall
quality is something us as paying
customers are all too familiar with so
today on the point we're gonna talk
about how development deadlines affect
creativity and we're gonna demonstrate
so by creating today's episode in one
day
[Music]
release deadlines are important they're
important to gamers to investors
developers and marketing departments a
game launched on October 1st will be
ready for the q4 holiday rush while a
game launch the day earlier on September
30th might be part of an entirely
different marketing budget the wheels of
commerce are intrinsically connected to
deadlines the clear space we can see
this is an annual releases games like a
Call of Duty Assassin's Creed Madden
FIFA and NHL game development is a time
intensive process but these games have
to be launched every single year in the
same pre-holiday window no matter what
what does this mean while essentially
the amount of design experimentation
that can happen on any one of these
games is severely limited but each new
game has to reach the expectation
watermark set by the previous year's
edition or face massive amounts of
negative consumer feedback what this
results in is a sort of iterative design
that abides by the law of diminishing
marginal returns in sovereign design we
call this feature creep every product
typically goes through a four stage
lifecycle introduction growth maturity
and decline we can apply this to many
game syriza's but for the sake of
simplicity let's go with call of duty
when cod for Modern Warfare came out it
was a rebirth of a series that
introduced a brand new type of
first-person shooter package a tight
single-player campaign alongside an
engaging multiplayer component now over
the course of the next few years they
expanded this design philosophy to make
more bombastic campaigns other wildly
expanded multiplayer mode with loads of
game types unlockables and classes and
it's fair to say that this concept
reached maturity around modern warfare 3
and ever since then the series to
struggle with adding new features which
gamers find interesting this has
resulted in decreased customer
satisfaction and ultimately decreased
sales 2007's Assassin's Creed introduced
a wonderful new type of open-world
gameplay and matured and expertly over
the course of the next few
but assassin's creed revelations was
most certainly a decline in every game
since then has been loading on new
features with mixed results Assassin's
Creed unity was already guilty of simply
trying to do too much but it was also a
buggy game with a lack of direction this
is the essence of feature creep when a
game fulfills its goal and subsequent
additions make it so top-heavy in
conversin that the functional simplicity
of the original idea is lost games often
become this top heavy and as annualized
franchises of such demanding deadlines
and don't allow consumers space to
breathe between each iteration this type
of decline is common in our industry
this is exactly what happened to the
Tony Hawk's franchise back in the day
it's fair to say that by th ps3 they had
pretty much nailed the formula but the
problem is Activision wanted to make
money so the developers were forced to
add new features to the game release it
every single year
even if these features feel unnecessary
and they have to do this with a limited
time frame to test them and on
increasingly aging foundations so it's
no wonder the game stopped selling the
same could be said of say Guitar Hero so
how do you combat feature creep well if
you don't have the time and resources to
add a bunch of new features to a game
then maybe you should lose this is what
FIFA does they sort of have their core
gameplay down and every year they add
piecemeal update so that rocking the
boat too much we had very little time to
do this episode which is why we're
recording in the back of a production
room not in a skate park or a field or
me on the beach in my underpants that
may result in a less impressive filed
product and hopefully the consumer is a
little bit satisfied experimentation is
costly and when the wheels of commerce
are so focused on immediate return on
investment it can cause talented people
to restrict themselves creatively
sometimes you spend a lot of time on
something new and it just doesn't work
our Tony Hawk episode last week for
instance considering the amount of time
that went into it it didn't exactly do
insane traffic but this is a
double-edged sword though tight
deadlines absolutely inhibit creativity
it's also good to have creative
boundaries they stop you from running
riot with your ideas creative people can
often lack focus so guidelines help
funnel
best ideas look at star citizen some
might suggest that the ever-increasing
budget this game has has actually been
detrimental to the original development
goal creative people hate being forced
into deadlines but they also don't want
to piss off their consumers so what if
the release date was a little less
defined it used to be that when a game
was finished it had to be finished when
a game went gold it was sent off to
production and shipped around the world
to stores
and then it had to be working by the
time the disk went into the players PC
or console but in the modern era digital
distribution has become more viable and
commonplace and this has allowed
developers the space to be more
ambiguous when it comes to the final
product deadlines you can now buy games
that are finished on Steam early access
you can buy Alfa's of games and be
involved in the development process bugs
and all but the biggest offender in
ambiguous deadlines syndrome is the
terrifying day one patch the majority of
games you buy today whether it be on PC
or console will ask you to update the
second you put them in dozens of games
now go gold packed full of bugs and
performance issues which are apparently
fixed in mandatory patches Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater 5 launched with a patch that
was bigger than the actual game and this
is a problem Daewon patches are the rope
by which many developers hang themselves
there a mechanism that allows developers
to work even closer to the deadline
without the option of a day one patch
wood games like Assassin's Creed unity
the Master Chief collection battlefield
4 and Batman Arkham Knight have launched
with such a litany of technical issues
and deadlines affect the overall quality
of a product absolutely perhaps this
episode could have been better written
maybe if I wasn't hopped up on benadryl
right now I'd be doing a better job by
presenting maybe Andy is doing a
terrible job on camera and maybe the
soundtrack could be better
in any case having not enough time for
something doesn't allow you to make the
best version of what you can make but
sometimes too much time could also be
detrimental games with long development
cycles win Game of the Year awards and
annualized franchises make a lot of
money so like many things this is a
balancing act ensuring that creative
people have the time to make their best
work without giving them the unbridled
freedom to lose focus so what's the
point I guess don't expect too much from
annualize franchises and go easy on
developers when games get delayed it
could be worse
it could be spending launch day
15 gigabytes of glue and duct tape
[Music]
you